Поки дружина у відрядженні Анатолій Момрик разом з дітьми
прикрашає квартиру до різдвяних та новорічних свят.
Вже і ялинку поставили, і невеликий вертеп з паперу зробили.
Ось це три царі,
ось це Йосип, ось це віслюк,
корова, овечка а це пастухи.
А ось до різдвяного столу ще поки нічого не купували, хоча і відтягувати нікуди.
Адже Різдво родина Момриків відзначає за григоріанським календарем 25 грудня.
Святвечір, який буде 24 числа, нічим не має відрізнятися
від того, що буде за старою традицією - 6 січня.
Він має складатися з пісних страв.
Я не буду сам робити вареники з капустою чи картоплею,
я просто їх куплю в магазині.
Можливо, куплю на базарі....
пісні голубці,
замість риби, бо діти її не люблять, куплю пресерви.
Але сама ідея, що це буде пісний стіл - буде збережена.
Зрозуміло, що буде кутя.
Хтось з рідних може прийти на Святвечір і шостого числа,
доведеться знову робити кутю.
По-іншому до Різдва готується родина Фаст.
У Центрі німецької культури Олександра закінчує оздоблювати різдвяний будиночок.
У Німеччині такі традиційні вироби продають
на різдвяних ярмарках.
І поки фарба висихає, господиня хизується -
головну страву на Святвечір вже приготувала.
Обов'язково штолен!
Він готується як мінімум за два тижні,
щоб настоявся.
А в старовину його готували взагалі за два місяці.
Для обох родин святкувати Різдво 25 грудня тепер значно простіше.
Адже вже третій рік як в Україні цей день - державний вихідний.
Такі зміни в календарі влада пояснила тим,
що приблизно третина усіх релігійних організацій в Україні
святкують Різдво за григоріанським календарем - 25 грудня.
Тому, мовляв, необхідно забезпечити права
цієї частини населення.
Крім того, загалом у світі більшість християнських церков
відзначає Різдво Христове саме 25 грудня -
зазначено в пояснювальній записці
до законопроекту.
Та хоча кількість прихильників цієї дати зростає,
переважна більшість українців
продовжують відзначати Різдво 7 січня.
Про це свідчать опитування, які протягом останніх років
проводили фонд "Демократичні ініціативи"
таЦентр Разумкова.
Так, наприкінці минулого року
намір святкувати Різдво традиційно у січні
озвучило 69% українців.
Неоднозначно ставляться до цього
й опитані нами віряни.
Церква як буде святкувати двадцять п'ятого,
прийдемо до церкви і 25-го,
але дома сьомого, як і було.
У нас є певні традиції, я зі Сходу України,
ми звикли святкувати все ж таки сьомого і будемо святкувати сьомого
і  дякуємо владі за додатковий вихідний.
Багато людей святкують двадцять п’ятого,
але ми звикли сьомого то будемо сьомого.
Сьомого як було так сьомого хай і буде.
Не нами заведено - не нами і міняти.
Але якщо Владика Епіфаній перенесе на 25 грудня?
Не можу сказати нічого, але я не вітаю це...
Якщо він дасть благословення,
то ми можемо і двадцять п’ятого і сьомого.
Але це тільки, якщо він дасть благословення.
Краще сьомого січня, але якщо буде 25 грудня,
то ми підтримаємо і будемо 25.
Я святкую разом зі своєю церквою сьомого січня. Перейде церква, то перейду і я.
Після того, як в Україні відбулося об'єднання православної церкви,
дискусія про перенесення Різдва
серед громадськості пожвавилася.
Про таке бажання заявив і предстоятель Православної церкви України владика Епіфаній.
Та наразі, кажуть у пресслужбі ПЦУ,
ще не зафіксовано жодної парафії, де більшість вірян
висловилася б за перехід на святкування 25 грудня.
Тому з реформою поки не поспішатимуть.
Спершу належним чином поінформують вірян.
Найперше в соціальних мережах.
ПЦУ активно відповідає і пояснює на запитання читачів,
коли святкувати Різдво.
Також наші священнослужителі говорять про це в проповідях.
Це наш основний меседж та основне місце,
де ми можемо проповідувати і людям пояснювати про святкування Різдва Христового.
Ми не будемо казати про кількість років.
Церква побачить, коли українське суспільство
буде готове перейти
до святкування Різдва 25 числа.
Анатолій Момрик, за фахом історик та етнограф,
докладно пояснює, чому виникла така різниця
у східній та західній традиції святкування Різдва
та чому з точки зору Євангеліє
логічніше святкувати народження Христа
до Нового Року.
Різдво відбулося десь в короткий проміжок часу:
між зимовим сонцестоянням і першим січнем. Бо 1 січня -
це завершення фінансового року в Римській імперії
нагадаю, за Євангелієм, саме тому Йосип і Марія мусили їхати
з Назарету до Вифлеєму, тому що там 1 січня
мусив бути перепис населення для оподаткування.
І ви пам'ятаєте,  він, приїхавши до Вифлеєму,
не знайшов місця де зупинитись і дитину  народили в хліву.
Тому зрозуміло, що це відбулося перед 1 січням,
але  після сонцестояння.
Анатолій Момрик вважає також міфом усталене уявлення про те,
що 25 грудня - це католицьке, а не православне Різдво.
Коректніше казати: західна і східна традиція святкування Різдва.
Утім, останніми роками святкування Різдва в Україні
дедалі більше нагадує західну традицію:
на кожному кроці продається глінтвейн
та запікають сосиски.
А ярмарки з різдвяними дерев’яними будиночками зовні нагадують європейські.
У церкві кажуть, що такі маркетингові кроки
також сприяють тому, щоб українці звикали до 25 грудня.
Принаймні молоді такі традиції вже значно ближчі.
Утім, прихильники церковно-календарної реформи мають розуміти,
що зміщується не лише святкування Різдва, але й інших релігійних свят.
Зокрема й улюбленець дітей Святий Миколай приходитиме до них на два тижні раніше.
У родині Момриків до таких змін ще не звикли.
Як і решта українських малюків, діти Анатолія
чекали на подарунки від Миколая 19, а не 6 грудня.